flawed character versus a train wreck or
is that what we want to see yeah we want
to see everybody train wrecked you you
want to see everybody in a room
grappling with their flaws I mean I'm in
a story like Mad Men everybody had a
deep core wound
Peggy's core wound is she's a she's a
woman in a man's world but she thinks
like a man she was damaged deeply Joan
has this deep core wound I'm only a sex
object right and that and by the way
these didn't heal right at the end of
the show she's still dealing with Joan's
still dealing with the fact that she
essentially hoard herself out with this
car executive and he's not taken
seriously by men yes they never heal but
it is the core wounds that when they
bump up against each other in the story
that makes you want to watch them and
audiences never need to know this but if
you ask yourself why a character's
interesting you're looking at it's
almost always because of that how are
they bleeding right the other thing Don
did because he was unlovable is he made
up an entire story about who he was he
took someone else's identity yeah he
took the identity of a guy who was
killed in Korea again I'm not lovable I
couldn't be loved for me I gotta be
somebody else so it's always there in a
great story there's never a story that
it's not another spit wasn't true 20
years ago but we've become a more
sophisticated audience in the United
States we really do want depth of
character that we didn't need 20 years
ago
and that's only going to continue
stories as sore like Louie which is a
television series with this great comic
it's nothing but him bleeding every week
in surprising ways confessing things
that sort of make our teeth be set on
edge but it's compelling to watch
someone confess confession is riveting
whenever I confess a personal wound of
mine in a classroom
everybody's gonna I've been talking a
long time it everyone just stops there's
total silence
in the room they're looking at me they
want to know and this is why you can't
lie about your core wound because that's
what people want to do oh geez I can't
see the truth so I'm going to make
something up let me see uh yeah okay my
mom molested me when I was four you
can't make it up why because we have
infinitely good detectors as
audiences we will know I can always tell
in a story when someone's telling me
something isn't true or isn't their
experience we know immediately you've
got to tell the truth or audiences will
be bored so whatever your pain is you
can't lie it's the truth that makes
people want to watch you why do we love
confessions why do we well what is it
let me ask you what's your deepest most
personal embarrassing secret I'll tell
you what a camera's uh uh there's
there's exactly exactly but if you were
to tell me now I would love hearing it
why my only sense would be because then
you could measure your own against what
I'm telling that's right and then go I
guess I'm not that bad after all
maybe or I'm not alone okay I'm you're
in you're in pain so am I now I
understand you now I empathize with you
now you're you're like me now it's the
story about me it's not some wonderful
person who's leading a perfect life that
I might fantasize about enjoy as a
reality show or a Kardashian show but
it's the deeper part of our lives which
is I'm in pain I I don't have everything
I want
are you like me oh my god you are thank
you
now I'll follow you because if you can
get better I can get better empathizing
with the character is all about
confession if you'll notice in a great
story confession of your core wound or
the core wound is something that happens
almost immediately in great stories you
want to show the characters wound and
his compensation often in the first 10
minutes of the show in a movie that's
certainly true
the quicker you show it the better the
empathy will be for it for the audience
don't hide it make everything and every
scenes about it every scenes about the
core wound and about how you're either
curing it or making it worse and every
character in a movie is only ripping at
the wound or healing it that's all it is
movies are just think of think of a
movie story as a boxing ring and the
hero jumps into the ring but he's
bleeding he starts out bleeding and the
whole movie is just people jumping in
with bandages to help him heal or people
jumping in with knives to rip it wider
open in a television story that just
continues for season after season but
it's the same thing
you